I would have thought the logical
progression after jurassic park would be
Jurassic land apparently was skipping
that going straight to world so the
first trailer for Jurassic world has hit
and this was not something I was
planning to talk about I my interest in
the movies kind of a morbid curiosity if
I'm being honest but the thing is the
reactions that I've seen to this trailer
which tend to lean rather heavily
towards nostalgic its excitement they
all seem to be missing a couple of
things that really immediately took me
out of interest for this thing now I'm
about to do something that geeks get
picked on a lot for doing and i will
pick on geeks for doing which is to grab
on to one or two minor details and just
pick the heck out of them before I do
that though maybe I should get a little
bit of context I come from a generation
of people who worship the Jurassic Park
movies there are so many people my age
get was their first really life-changing
movie experience going to the theater
and seeing dinosaurs I love the original
Jurassic Park I think it is a fantastic
movie it's not a seminal in my life as I
think it was for a lot of people my age
but wonderful movie and I'm happy to own
it now some people have been sort of are
they got a tarnished Jurassic Park the
tarnishing has already happened with the
last two sequels lost world was my first
real experience in sequel itís which is
do the same movie again bigger which
almost never results in anything any
good the third drives a park I actually
think is a better movie than most people
credit for but again it's a general
downward trajectory so the fact that
there's all this excitement for this
seems to be rooted very much in the
original Jurassic Park which is fine i
guess they accept if all these people
knew the original dressing park as much
as their fandom would indicate they
should be noticing what i'm noticing
about this before i get there i will say
seeing the operational park is pretty
cool I'm sure the film is gonna look
great I'm a little bit worried about
Chris Pratt not because of him he'll do
as well as he can but the lies that he's
given in this trailer they're a bit
clunky I also don't like the fact that
it looks like they're gonna crowbar
another kid into this granted it makes a
little bit more organic sense that
there's gonna be a kid this time because
of the parks open there's gonna be kids
all over the place but we had crowbarred
kids in the last Jew sequels can we just
do this without a kid this time but
those are mine cuz there's those are
things i could have kind of gotten over
here comes the nit picky thing so the
main crux of the trailer is this notion
that they have created a whole new
dinosaur a hybrid
you know they've got the genetic
materials they're gonna mix them in a
new amalgamation create something
totally different I like this on paper
but Bryce Dallas Howard has a line that
killed it for me she says we've created
the first hybrid wait a minute haven't
these things always been hybrids
actually I'm pretty sure was a major
plot point in the first movie that they
had their DNA spliced with frogs which
allowed them to change sex and therefore
breed in the wild these are not your
first hybrids every dinosaur you've ever
pumped out has been a hybrid and i know
this is nitpicky i said that up front
this just shows a disregard for the film
that they're obviously wanting us to be
like oh I like that I'll come and see
this well you just you threw out a major
part of the mythology now to be fair the
Jurassic Park series has never done much
with that premise it was one of the
things from the book that I always kind
of wanted the movies to pick up and run
with a bit more in the book it's
actually kind of important the fact that
these things are basically not really
dinosaurs they're just mutations that
are made to look as close as possible to
dinosaurs they're not even designed to
live that long that's why you may
remember the first movie there's this
little side thing about the Triceratops
is sick but they're not sure why and it
gets dropped later on well that's from
the book the reason they're sick is just
because they're not built to last
they're built to look nice for the
tourists and then die because they're
not the real thing however the movies
have always kind of gone with the notion
of yet these are dinosaurs that's them
look at them walking around how awesome
it is awesome dinosaur walking around is
awesome but it's never done anything
with the notion that these are
artificial creations if they're creating
a custom dinosaur they're doing more
with the idea but just that line to me
it's just a big red flag there's the
possibility that maybe this is an insert
line just being used for the trailer and
it's not in the film itself but then
there's the other things buggy and me
like how bad Chris Pratt's lines are in
the fact that there's a clue that
there's gonna be another kid I just Oh
guys I I'm getting not good feelings off
this trailer so that's me here to spoil
all your fun and dampen your excitement
and until next time this council is
adjourned